chacun des mots julie depardieu
guillaume debart
bon sang
au pouvoir jeanne moreau bon soir ou
jamais dans un bon soir julie des parts
du bon soir guillaume depardieu bonsoir
êtes ici tous les trois pour les rois
maudits la grande fiction de prestige
que france 2 diffusera à partir du 7
novembre
alors au départ les rois maudits c-17
volume écrit par maurice druon en 1955
adapter une première fois à la
télévision par claude barma le papa de
catherine voilà ça a été un des grands
événements de la rtf c'est vraiment un
feuilleton culte de la télévision ce qui
n'a pas empêché josée dayan ne s'y
recoller avec anne-marie qu'à toi pour
le scénario est la peur de rien josé on
se tape le truc le plus énorme de lower
tf
elle leur fait courageuses n'ont
toujours très courageuse
ouais prenantes josy semences une vraie
feuilletoniste quoi au sens noble du
terme à la fée monte cristo elle a fait
les misérables et la febea qu'elle a un
souffle comme ça là à la dumas
un peu comme les grands feuilletonistes
du 19e siècle et puis elle s'est
fabriqué monté fabriqué ouais elle va
vite un way commencé pour les acteurs
c'est emballant ces jours ci dans
l'histoire des rois maudits c'est la
malédiction qui pèse sur fip lebel et
ses successeurs
car tu connais l'histoire lorient sur
les brûlés vifs jacques de molay le
grand maître de l'ordre des templiers
parce qu'ils avaient trop de pouvoir et
le tipi dit maudit soyez tous maudit
pendant treize générations là mais c'est
aussi le combat que se livrent mahaut
d'artois incarné par jeanne moreau et
robert d'artois incarné par philippe
torreton pour la possession du comté
d'artois voilà mais elle a une fille
ella deux filles d'antigua lada dont une
julie vous êtes jeunes de poitiers de la
fille de mao faisait fi de poitiers qui
est le fils du roi philippe le bel voilà
c'est un vantant d'avoir un roi comme
gendre voilà et l'autre fils du roi mais
c'est vous guillaume
louis 10 le utah c'est ce que ça veut
dire le hutin maintenant le désagréable
fantasque mairie cas je vais quéral et
qui n'a pas vraiment de ce que très
agréable dans cette série c'est qu'il ya
un mélange d'acteurs incroyable il ya
des gens de l'ancienne génération on
retrouve jean claude drouot qui faisait
thierry la fronde alors en plus il a il
est chauve il a une tête ah oui on
dirait mars jean claude ollier daniel
emile fort que si tu te souviens tu
connais très bien
grand acteur l'astrologue way in fine à
soi que j'avais le maître martin il a
besoin de temps il ya jean claude brialy
claude rich
cki carillo jeanne moreau voilà et puis
aussi vous 2 julie et guillaume ya julie
gayet il ya hélène fillières il ya un
mélange de plusieurs générations
d'acteurs qui se retrouvent là
évidemment ça se passe
ça se passe très bien quoi mon bien
voilà alors qu'elle est extraordinaire
c'est que cette saga à un peu
shakespearienne elle est traitée comme
un space opera on est dans une espèce de
moyenâgeux futuriste avec des décors de
philippe druillet qui a fondé métal
hurlant et c'est vrai que c'est drôle
voilà je sais c'est extraordinaire
d'avoir fait appel à lui c'est une super
idée les costumes de milan pika et puis
beaucoup d'effets spéciaux de trucages
numériques ce qui fait que ça se regarde
très bien à quoi je ne sais pas du tout
je me dise pas du tout une série
historique chien alors tout est très
dessiné un par exemple vous vous avez la
mèche blanche et puis toujours une robe
violette intendant pendant tout le film
quoi voilà
et puis torreton lullaby en rouge son
cheval est habillé en rouge enfin c'est
très bande dessinée en même temps c'est
vrai que c'est très facile d'accès voilà
alors on va je vais m'arrêter
assurez-vous on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble je vais regarder tous les
trois votre caméra et vous allez lire en
même temps sinon ça marchera pas tu es
trop attention vous aider en même temps
magnéto serge khalfon je sais c'est
compliqué mais il faut 2
le mans sur toi nous avons pas prendre
ces moments là je le sens pas si son
visage qui prend surtout alors attention
attention à ton âge de sens et je t'ai
dit vas-y j'étais en train de parler
allez-y m'en aller attention à 3 a
souvent un mais vous le ratez pas le nom
c'est bien plus dur en même temps ils le
savent que j'ai le plus haut dans une
sur sur un deux trois à l'étang serge
pas mal